سنه 2022 شاره فتعل الانتهاء سنه شهدت
انتعاشا كبيرا في مجال السفر والسؤال الذي
يطرحه خبراء السياحه اين تتوجه الامطار في
السنه المقبله على كل حال اذا كنت تبحث عن
مكانا مثالي لمغامرتك المقبله فان موقع
لبنات اصدر قائمه تولي افضل الوجهات
السياحيه حول العالم لعام 23 23 القائمه
اخذت شكلا جديدا هذه السنه حيث تم تقسيم
الوجوهات الثلاثين التي تم اختيارها الى
خمس فئات هي الطعام والتعلم والمغامرات
والاسترخاء والتواصل للتعرف على هذه
المواجهات مع كلاميز
اليكم افضل الاماكن للسفر التي شملتها
قائمه لوني بلانيت لعام 2023 فاذا كانت
غاياتك الاكل وتذوق اطباق تعد الافضل في
العالم فعليك بزياره وعمرها في ايطاليا
كوالالمبور في ماليزيا فوكاكا في اليابان
لما فيبيرو جنوب افريقيا في اوروغواي اما
اذا كنت تسافر
بزياره اسطنبول في تركيا صوفيا في بلغاريا
والقسم الغربي من استراليا والتحميه
الطبيعيه الوطنيه
فعليك بالذهاب الى مانشستر في المملكه
المتحده
كان في المانيا السلفر جنوب اسكتلندا
ومرسيليا في فرنسا وبما ان الاردن في هذه
القائمه الزميله سهير جميل تسحبنا في رحله
عبر ما لدى المملكه من وجهه سياحيه
[موسيقى]
هنا الاردن فلنربط الاحزمه استعدادا
للانطلاق في جوله سياحيه نلف بها البلاد
خلال دقائق
عمان حيث سياحه الاثاري حاضره
فمن جبل القلعه الى المدرج الروماني تذكره
الزمن تعود بالسائح لالاف السنين
[موسيقى]
المتعه لم تبدا بعد خاصه مع انضمام الاردن
لافضل 30 وجهه سياحيه عالميه على مستوى
العالم للعام 2023
فان كانت الوجهه لسياحه العلاجيه فالطريق
لاخفض بقعه في العالم حيث يستقبلك البحر
الميت فيما ستكون حمامات ماعين بانتظارك
بشلالاتها الساخنه
وان كنت من محبي المغامره فما عليك سوى
الذهاب لجبال عجلون و وادي الموجب لتكون
ما بين تسلق الجبال تاره والغوص في المياه
تاره اخرى
[موسيقى]
عجائب الدنيا السبع المدينه الورديه هذه
حكايه البتراء التي تعد ايضا احدى وجهات
ما يعرف بالمثلث الذهبي صحراء وجبالها
تستوقفك بسحرها الفريد يستمر المسير حتى
العقبه مدينه سياحه الاردنيه بامتياز حيث
البحر واعماقه التي يتفرد بها عن باقي
بحار العالم
[موسيقى]
تختلف الوجهه باختلاف رغبه السائح وكل
الخيارات متاحه
نتجه للشمال حيث جرش مدينه الاثار
الرومانيه مدينه تجمع الفن والثقافه
والتاريخ وتقدم كافه الخيارات لزوارها
مادبا حيث تتفردوا هذه الاماكن بالسياحه
الدينيه
لم تنتهي الجوله بعد لكن الرحله على وشك
الانتهاء فان اردت اكمالها فما عليك الا
زياره الاردني لاستكشافها كبلد تميز وتفرد
على خارطه السياحه العالميه
[موسيقى]
الى فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا في
الاستوديو الجميله سمر الماشطه دائما صحفي
يقسم الاقتصاد يسعد صباحك الاسود
كبير في اسعار التذاكر تذاكر طيارات وحتى
في الفنادق هل من الانفراج العام المقبل
20 30 23
20% من التكلفه بس التكلفه الاخرى اللي هي
65% لا مستمره بالارتفاع اللي هي تكاليف
قال همم تكاليف
عندك مثلا التعاكس المفروضه على الطائره
لا اتكلم عن الطائره لحد الان نتكلم عن
تذكره الطائره فعندك التاكس المفروضه
اليوم عندنا مشكله تصير بين المطارات وبين
شركات الطيران انه المطارات اليوم تفرض
رسوم بعد اعلى على هذه الطائرات حتى تنزل
عندها المطار
انه همم
لما هتسافرين للاكل والشرب الى اخرها هاي
كلها راح تستمر بالارتفاع وخصوصا ارتفاع
سفر رجال الاعمال هذه السنه ارتفع على
الشخص الواحد
حتى يروح رجل اعمال الى كونفرنس ويحضر
مؤتمر ارتفعت التكاليف 25% على رجل
الاعمال الواحد
وارتفعت التكاليف 50
من الارتفاع على سفاره الرجال
طيب طيب سمر بالنسبه لاهم ترامب جهاد اهم
انماط السفر المقبله خلال عام 20 من
الاشياء المثيره ان شاء الله ناويه اسويها
مهمين انه هناك اليوم اللي هي التورز عبر
الدراجه الهوائيه هناك العديد من الشعر
عبر الدراجه العاديه يعني هناك العديد من
الشركات تظهر اليوم هذا القطاع لوحده
اليوم اكثر من 40 مليار دولار اللي هو
السفر عبر البايسكل الاول الدراجه هناك
العديد من الشركات تغطي طول او جوله تغطي
كل اوروبا انت تختارين الخط اللي تريديه
وتروحين عليه واحده من الواتساب اللي هي
يورو هذا من اشهر الواد سيد العين اللي
يقوم بهذه التورس والحلو فيه انه يكون
ارخص لانه همم
يعني مثل بيت خشبي وتشتركين مع اخرين فيه
اللي حاب يرجع الى الطبيعه اللي حبيبتي
تكون اغلى بكثير خصوصا تكاليف الاكل
والشرب والتنقل الى اخره فهذه من الحلو
في ايطاليا
حتى تطلعي همم الجبل كان مرتفع كثير
دراجه هوائيه كانت تجربه كثير
مخيمات
مثلا وتنامين في مخيمات يعني كل مره
قطاع السفر 246 مليار دولار انه غير انه
هناك همم المونديال طبعا فهناك العديد من
المشاريع الخاصه والحكوميه في السعوديه
هناك العديد من المشاريع السياحيه التي
تشجع السياحه ايضا عوده السياحه المعتمرين
والحجاج وايضا من المتوقع انه 286 مليار
دولار بعد تقريبا ست سنوات
القادمه اول شيء من الاشياء اللي مهمه جدا
واللي ايضا انا اكتبيها مؤخرا اللي هي
الكريدت كارت اللي بتعطيك ايرمايلز لتعتيك
مايلز او نقاط على السفر هاي مهمه ثانيا
نحاول نلقي شخص او عائله اخرى نسافر معها
واليوم يق- يقال ثري ستارز از ذا نيو فور
ستايز اليوم او طبعا احنا يمكن بالمنطقه
لانه متعودين شويه يمكن الفورد ستارز
ستارز اليوم ايضا هناك السفر المستدام
ومثل ما قلنا انه نروح شويه للطبيعه بعيدا
عن السيتيز شكرا جزيلا شكرا شكرا